sie versüßt dir die weihnachtszeit
du siehst du gar schneit dich mit backen
vom alltag und frei sie verwies mit
weiten von alt sagte freund
das ist
es liest
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys wenn ich
heute ein leckeres weihnachtliches für
euch also ich habe ein leckeres
weihnachtliches bisher für euch ich habe
mir überlegt was könnte man machen zum
beispiel für einen machen nach so ein
weihnachtsmenü wieder und noch klarer
wird nach dem kartoffelsalat und
würstchen genau passt dass er auf jeden
fall das ist heute ein sehr einfaches
her was man auch dann mal kurzfristig
vorbereiten kann
wenn ihr zum beispiel songs wie mousse
au chocolat machen wollt oder irgend wie
tiramisu müsst ihr das hat lange zeit im
kühlschrank lassen am besten über nacht
und da eignet sich dieses ist super wenn
man einfach mal ganz schnell am
weihnachtstag noch kurz was machen
möchte okay man ja aber ich möchte noch
kurz erzählen was drinsteckt und zwar
habe ich da unten ein lebkuchenteig mit
drin habe auch ein paar lebkuchen mit
dabei
dann ist sie eine rote grütze mit
kirschen und himbeeren und eine leckere
creme ausmaß capone und schmand nur noch
lästig ist kann man das auch noch mit
humor zum beispiel oder man kann einen
likör mit rein geben oder etwas
kirschwasser oder einfach was er gerne
möchte
ja und jetzt fangen wir direkt an für
den zeit brauche ich zwei eier 2
esslöffel heißes wasser 60 gramm zucker
etwas vanille extrakt eine prise salz
hier habe ich 30 gramm mehl und 30 gramm
schweiße stellten schon gemischt 15
gramm kakaopulver 1 esslöffel
lebkuchengewürz und ein teelöffel
backpulver und das ist jetzt ein ganz
normaler biskuitteig deswegen geht es
auch ganz schnell kommen zuerst die eier
in die rösler gemeinsam mit dem heißen
wasser da lassen sie sich einfach besser
aufschlagen dann der zucker mit rainer
etwas vanille
ich weiß natürlich alex praktisch im
monat verbraucht so stimmig und dann
wird es schön cremig gerührt
jetzt ist die einmal so schön cremig
seht ihr auch hier also richtig schön
voluminös und den rest also die
trockenen zutaten die hebe ich jetzt nur
unter
wir werden jetzt aber noch kurz durch
gesiegt
und ich sie die einfach immer ganz genau
durch damit ich keine klümpchen im teig
gehabt und das hat eben auch lockerer
wird so jetzt kurz unterheben
und jetzt wird der teig in meinem
backform ein gefühl ich habe seinen
eckigen back rahmen bereits eingestellt
auf die größte größe und da wird er dann
im vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 10 grad
für ungefähr acht minuten gebacken
während datei gibt's noch in offenbach
kann ich schon mal die füllung zwar
bereiten da mache ich jetzt so eine rote
grütze und habe diese zutaten hier
und zwar hier ein glas sauerkirschen 200
gramm tiefgekühlte hin bern
ich habe 20 gramm stärke 1 esslöffel
zucker mit zimtstange etwas merke also
getrocknete gemahlene nelken und ich
nehme noch ein upgrade von namen die
miete einfach so für den leckeren
weihnachtlich winterlichen geschmack und
ich gebe jetzt die kirchen direkt in den
topf erstmal nur ein bisschen dann kann
ich nämlich die stärke noch ganz schön
damit verrühren kommt nämlich die stärke
direkt betreiben wird das klümpchen frei
gerührt nur sein den rest mir dazu
dann kommt auch limettenschale mit rein
nur ein bisschen ist gute aroma dann
etwas merke den zucker mit rein und ich
geh jetzt mal die halbe zimtstange mit
rein und kochte es jetzt einmal kurz auf
so die größe sitz aufgekocht und auch
ein bisschen eingedeckt und jetzt gebe
ich auch noch die himbeeren mit rein
die sind ja richtig schön karls dann
kühlt es auch schnell herunter
und damit die grütze jetzt aber noch
schneller abkühlt völlig es noch um aus
dem kopf heraus dass jetzt auch die
zimtstangen erstmal noch drin dann kann
sie nämlich noch ihr aroma mit abgeben
und jetzt warte ich einfach nur kurz auf
meinen speed quartett ist es hier
abgekühlt ist man kümmert es hier sehr
gut zusammen setzen
der tie gesetz abgekühlt die kürzer habe
ich noch einen kühlschrank und jetzt
bereite ich schon mal die füllung vor
also die creme
dafür habe ich jetzt hier 250 gramm aus
gaborone 400 gramm schwanz 60 gramm
puderzucker und vanille extrakt da kommt
natürlich meter mit rein
jetzt versuche ich das alles ganz kurz
mit dem mit der küchenmaschine aber ein
handrührgerät geht natürlich auch da
könnte jetzt einfach alles rein geben
jetzt auch dieses mal keine sahne weil
das kaputte schon sehr viel fett enthält
und den puderzucker denn sie mich jetzt
rein da hat mich so viele klümpchen
nun gibt es nur ganz kurz rühren
dann kümmere ich mich jetzt um den teig
den löse ich jetzt einmal kurz aus der
form heraus mit einem taschenmesser
und stürzen dann direkt auf dem
schneidebrett
und jetzt muss ich ihn in kleine stücke
schneiden damit ich später einfach schön
schichten kann ich stecke jetzt aber
noch ein paar sterne aus später für die
dekoration die linke ich mir dann zur
seite
ich habe ein paar mehr steine
ausgesprochen weil ich einfach die
sterne mit drei schichten möchte und den
rest gebe ich jetzt einfach in eine
schüssel rein die sind ja schon schön
klein und den restlichen teig schneide
ich auch gleich noch knallen stelle ich
aber kurz zur seite
wer möchte kann jetzt übrigens noch ein
paar lebkuchenherzen mit reingeben das
mache ich jetzt auch noch schnell
deswegen schneidet jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen
jetzt habe ich alles vorbereitet und
jetzt kann ich alles bereits schichten
ich habe jetzt dafür drei so schöne
gläser genommen natürlich pass war jetzt
nicht alles rein
das soll jetzt einmal zu zeigen sein und
später zeige ich euch dann noch wie man
in so eine größere schale schichten kann
also könnt entscheiden portion er ist
direktor zunächst später am tisch und
ich zeige euch jetzt mal die mit wurde
dafür kommen jetzt die teigstücke unten
rein
jetzt kommt die lebkuchenherzen mit 3
die passen halt ganz gut weil sie
gefühlte mit marmelade
darauf kommt jetzt die rote grütze man
muss nur aufpassen dass ihr die
zimtstangen nicht erwischt
und dann kommt noch die creme obendrauf
als deko streue ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen zimt drüber
und ein bisschen schokolade da habe ich
eine schokoladen mühle
mit schicht ich den rest noch in eine
große schale damit es auch seht da mache
ich es aber mehrere schichten
die
das dessert ist fertig und ich hatte es
noch etwa eine stunde im kühlschrank als
wir länger als zieht umso besser wird
natürlich aber ihr könnt auch eigentlich
so nach einer halben stunde schon essen
so moritz darfst du probieren auch
richtig hübsch sind in den gläschen
große schale
sie steht man im kühlschrank probiert
mit mir ist gut wie heißes eisen ende
eines weißen hais nehme auf jeden fall
durch die gewürze also es kommt richtig
gut geld mit den lebkuchengewürz und dem
zimt richtig lecker und erfrischend denn
die sauerkirschen sind ja haben ja diese
säuerliche note und ich finde dann auch
nicht so süß
also auch was leicht das eigentlich so
ich esse jetzt fertig und wir das noch
machen wollte geht ihr einfach auf
meinem blog auf sally blog.de
da stehen noch mal das genaue rezept und
ich freue mich wenn es nach macht und
mir ein foto auf instagram oder facebook
schickt also bis zum nächsten mal
jurist wir schon verstärkt